Remember that membership is the number
one funding source for our little
show. You can sign up at join Pacman dot com.
I invite you to join the discussion with, at this
point, about 25000 other viewers and listeners
of the David Pakman show on our sub. Read it at
David Pakman dot com slash. Read it. That's our
EDI's DHT. Want to highlight a few posts from the
sub Reddit user reflex point pointed out various
mutely. I'm depressed that the race is even this
close, given how horrible of a person Trump is. I
just can't wrap my mind around the fact that Biden
is only up by nine points nationally and
could potentially lose the race if there are
huge polling errors in battleground states.
It's nauseating, disgusting and depressing
that this many Americans, after four years of
what we've seen, want four more years of it.
I'm so far past saying we need to understand what
drove these people to Trump. He bullied Gretchen
Whitmer, who was threatened to be kidnaped and
murdered by right wing armed thugs. That alone
should cost him the election, let alone the
10000 other things he's done at this point.
I can barely even remember anymore because they
were so numerous. Yeah. And this gets back to
this idea that win or lose, after the election,
we have 60 million plus trumpet's in this country
that are, you know, debasing education,
completely divorced from the realities of
how the world works. I mean, the whatever focus
you want to pick there for whatever slice of
those 60 million people you're more concerned
with, that is a real problem. And Trump should
be down 80 point. I mean, he ought to be treated.
Nobody should be voting for Donald Trump. If the
world makes it made sense, nobody would be
voting for Donald Trump. User pumpkin pie,
six, six, six, pumpkin pie six, six, six says
very aggressively you are politically useless
if you don't vote. It doesn't matter what your
views are, how much David Pakman you listen to,
how much news you consume or how active you are
on political Twitter. If you don't cast a ballot.
Voting is the only viable path to change in
the direction we want. Trump can still win
all of the protests, impeachment. All of the
backlash against Trump will have been totally
meaningless if we don't actually show up and vote
him out. You're not a hero for not voting. You're
irrelevant. You're politically useless no matter
how informed you are on the issues. The left may
pull a 2016 and self immolate again by refusing to
participate. Don't be one of those people or the
next four years may be worse than the last four.
I don't know that I would word it as aggressively,
but the sentiment there is fair, which is there's
much more that we can do in addition to voting,
but we all have to vote. That's the starting
point. If we're not voting, what are we doing?
Join the discussion. I'm inviting you
at David Pakman dot com slash. Read it.